so why don't you stop and then hi
everybody my name is Joe touch I'm an
independent consultant and my website is
stray alpha calm as you can see on this
title page here I've been a research
professor at USC I aside for about
twenty five years doing internet
research recently went to the Aerospace
Corporation in El Segundo here and have
been working on satellite networks since
then and my co-author here is Dave
Farber who was my PhD adviser 27 28
years ago
gasps yeah yeah who is now visiting at
Keio University in Tokyo and we're going
to be speaking about rebooting the
Internet their websites that you see on
the page here are up and they are the
best way to find me and myself a day
okay so hey did you want to give a brief
introduction yeah
yeah I'm Dave father obviously I'm
distinguished professor at Keio
University in Tokyo Japan been here for
two years here at least the next year so
I mean the virus doesn't destroy
everything around here the besides being
a professor kale I co-chair with Jim
Murray the Center for cyber civilization
Research Center which is a activity at
Ko that encompasses a whole bunch of
activities from computer security to
medical informatics a bunch of stuff
that relates to where our civilization
is going courtesy of cyber this subject
to rebooting the Internet has interested
me for a long time the putting a little
bit of history in this internet really
started out as an experiment you know
try to do packet switching and trying to
use that as a vehicle between computers
it was an experiment
and experiments have happened of
sometimes doing things sites sometimes
doing things wrong there were a lot of
issues that were just not considered
when the when the early that research
was done like security and a bunch of
other things we thought enough to get
the thing running
plowing new ground so in fact a lot of
things work were ignored the other thing
that's happened is that we've gone from
a world where we had you know basically
56 kilobits circuits at best so now
where we have gigabit circuits at least
we now have wireless which we didn't
have back then a whole bunch of things
that have changed things dramatically
some things have not changed they've
evolved and the evolution may or may not
have been always in the right direction
and that's one of the things we're going
to explore today and Joe is going to get
most of the talks most of the talk we
put on your for the students to do that
I won't go there right now so I'm going
to turn this over to Joe there's a
number of things at the CCRC website
which is there some talks I gave mchao
which amplify some of these issues so
I'll be available for questions and I'm
always available for email Joe take it
off and also to give credit where
credit's due
Dave had given a talk back in I think
was January University somewhat
extemporaneously and sent me the video
and asked what I thought of it and I
sent him back I think this is the
outline of the talk that this was and it
accidentally leaked out and we've got an
invitation to present we're very very
happy we did because it gave us an
opportunity to develop the material into
a talk and I'm very happy as to point
out as well this is actually the first
time that Dave and I can do the talk
together that's right I'm trying okay so
as an overview we're going to go through
a bunch of things here first we're going
to explain the need for rebooting and
then we'll go through the pros and cons
on the Internet
I know that everybody knows the pros and
loves the pros of the Internet there are
costs and there are quite a few so go
through those as well then we're gonna
throw some stumps and see if we can
break some windows the only way you can
figure out how to redesign something
used to know what's broken so we're
gonna see if we can break things okay
and then we're gonna give you an example
of a different way of looking at
networking that I happen to have
developed when I was at USC which is
originally a way of looking at layering
turned into a new way of teaching
computer networks but it will give you
that sense of things are a little bit
different now and maybe if we look at
things differently we get a different
answer then we will discuss the
challenge of transition anytime you want
to go from the old to the new you can't
just turn it off and jump that makes
things hard and then we'll have some
concluding remarks as we mentioned at
the beginning there are websites on the
first page there reiterated on the last
page there's also a bunch of resources
on the last page that you can click to
as well on our pages as well to link to
ok so my way of introduction and
background this all started with the
idea of systems design the adage says
Bill will want and throw it away because
the first time you do it it's gonna be
wrong and it's not whether it's gonna be
wrong it's when it's gonna be wrong and
one of the first people to put this down
in writing was bricks read books wrote
this this wonderful book called the
mythical man-month you haven't read it
you should it's not very long and it's
got a lot of really interesting points
in it and one of them is here it's build
one throw it away because your first
system is always going to have certain
kinds of mistakes and there's no way
around but these point to get a much
deeper point about systems architecture
and we're going to discuss that there's
different kinds of ways of rebooting
things you can do an in-place
incremental modification you can update
you can extend and we've been doing that
with the internet for
were nearly 40 40 some years or so you
cannot so at some point it
control-alt-delete as they say in
Windows parlance and just replace
everything it turns out that didn't
happen with the internet back in 1983
the first version of the Internet was a
protocol called the network control
protocol NCP and it was a redesign a
significant redesigning the architecture
and the protocols that happened that
gave us tcp/ip and there was a day day
before that year an NCP day after that
you ran TCP and that has a very dramatic
effect it allows you to not have to
carry a lot of baggage with you about
the old way of doing things but it also
needs it's a very abrupt change many of
you may have heard about the clean slate
projects and the clean slate approaches
so this is the idea that instead of
being stuck with what you were started
with you erase the board and you notice
back when people had chalkboards and you
erased the slate and you come up with a
new way of approaching things I think
that clean slate is wonderful when the
clean sakes project happens back in
around 2000 or so I reminded everybody
that it's at least how most people like
me would start Monday by erasing the
board so but then I put an idea on it I
think it's not about the clean it's
about the idea that you put on the clean
slate ok what is our connection we're
going to talk about systems architecture
and network architecture architecture is
not this very vague concept it is it
does have a definition it's the
description of a system and how it
behaves through listing its components
the component behaviors and properties
the way the components interact and the
way they behave as a whole and by
describing a system that way you're
saying what you want the system to do
and how to break it into manageable
chunks that interact with each other
that is architecture there's different
ways of looking at architecture but
there are all kinds they're all variants
of the same thing
this is how we built the Eiffel Tower
it's you're in the background there
um that's also how we built the internet
to some extent as we had an architecture
when you are building a large system
there are a lot of intertwined
components there's networking there's
processing there's operating systems and
anytime you do any one of those things
or any of those together you have this
opportunity to design the pieces that
you're putting together at the same time
the hardware and the software the
inboard processing and the outboard
processing the library the applications
okay you can Co design the pieces as you
go and take advantage of the best parts
of each right if it's hard to do in
hardware maybe it's easier to do in
software it's easy to do in software
harder to eat you know back and forth or
you can let everybody do their own thing
and then retrofit and correct it and
that turns out to be really really
really hard so getting these pieces
right getting the interactions between
them right and sometimes having that
balance of knowing what to put into what
BIM is an integral part of what
architecture is you are the phrases
right-sizing you're picking the right
size of the chunks of your system okay
you always have to reboot things there
is no getting around it there's very few
things and work in the world or in life
that you get once of and it never
changes and it's always fine and there's
two reasons the first thing is sometimes
you couldn't get what you want as the
stones used to say and sometimes you get
what you need and your needs have
changed so it's either that what you you
didn't know you knew what you wanted but
you couldn't get or a flying car want a
flying car
I don't have a flying car someday maybe
I will have a flying car we'll have to
redesign cars to fly okay but also I
started off wanting a flying car because
I wanted to get from one place to the
next fast so that I can get to many
meetings well here we are on the
internet having a meeting didn't need a
flying car to get there but what I need
is bandwidth so my needs have changed
right now we've never watched the old
TV show specials with Charlie Brown and
Lucy Charlie Brown always ran up to kick
the football Lucy always pulled the
football away and changed the game okay
and that happens to us all the time when
we're building a system the goals change
in the beginning of the internet it was
about designing a system for inner
interpersonal communication doing what
we're doing right now email messaging
video right and also remote work like
remote loggin that we take for granted
was hard back then and that was what it
was for it wasn't designed to survive a
nuclear attack that's a legend but it's
not actually a direct origin story of
what was going on here and the internet
may have wished it could handle voice
and video but in the beginning nobody
was thinking of that as they've
mentioned the band widths were way too
small and just wasn't a consideration
and it was not designed to scale it has
scaled wonderfully it was nobody sat
down and said what happens when to bid
two billion people are on the Internet
okay you think about telephones
telephones are just one step in an
evolution of telecommunication the first
telecommunication was actually text
messaging it was the Telegraph okay and
then we changed our mind and said no we
don't want just text we want to talk to
the person on the other end then we
wanted to email them now we want a video
and some of you are more comfortable
emailing and texting than you are
picking up a phone and that's fine but
that's saying that the goals change you
also get outdated questions back in the
stone Age's when I started in this field
in the mid 1980s there was a lot of
money being spent trying to figure out
how to do video over a voice line over a
56k line and there was a couple of
reasons for that one as everybody wanted
you teleconference and that was all you
could get and the other is the deaf
people wanted to do sign language and if
you were doing sign language you could
at least see the signs if you had video
and there was a lot of work trying to
figure out how you do sign language over
a phone one
how do you compress voice under 8
kilohertz how do you get under 7 bits of
sample we don't ask those questions
anymore we don't ask them so don't have
to okay so we have to change things now
Dave my adviser has had a principle for
many many years but alcohol Farber's
principle which is that resources change
I think the adage that you have Dave is
that every 20 years you can go back and
pick an old systems paper pick it up and
look at it and whatever assumptions
they're making ask yourself are they
still true now think about 20 years ago
did you have a disk that was bigger than
you could ever want
did you have bandwidth that was bigger
than you could ever want did you have a
screen with more resolution than you
could ever want did you have a system
that did all that that you could fit in
your pocket no so the resources changing
changes what becomes feasible again when
we started in this field when I started
in this field one of the first things I
bought for myself was a hard drive
because you'd have a million floppies
first hard drive I bought had five
megabytes of information okay I only
ever thought of what I could do with
five meagan information I would never
get where I was where I am today okay
five Meg is one song one you only get to
listen to one song on your iPod forever
that's all it is so by thinking ahead by
looking at how things scale we get
different answers to different questions
there are things we don't do anymore we
used to pay money for software that
would compress RAM that would compress
data on the disk that would cache things
on the disk we don't do that anymore
it's too cheap you what you call a GPU
we used to call a supercomputer and it
took up a room it's largely the same
thing it was a SIMD special-purpose
computer okay and there were there was a
time when when you put something in
memory you didn't know if it was going
to be there or change very much and so
you had to have a lot
check sums on it you don't have those
anymore largely the check sums and error
codes that we have in our protocols are
there to check softer monks not hardware
failures
now there's another story that's useful
to understand here Einstein it was a
professor at Princeton University who
was teaching a class and he gave a final
exam and he passed the exam out to the
students and one of the students went up
to him and said dr. Hanson I don't
understand what are you doing here is
what do you mean is you givin me the
same questions you gave the students
last year how's that helpful you know
you know with you I knew the questions
from last year I knew the answers right
now here you're repeating the questions
and Einstein said that's okay the
questions are the same but the answers
are changing okay and so again when we
ask a question can I do something how
much bandwidth does this take is
bandwidth even something I want to
minimize the answers change so even if
the questions don't changing the answers
do we get a different answer a different
system okay the big thing about systems
architecture is when you design it you
don't know what you're doing nobody does
it's very rare that you start a system
off with a set of specific requirements
that will make a customer or a user
happy forever and you build to that you
design to what you know at the time you
start building but that really is what
you needed to know when you started now
years later you look at the system and
realize gee if I only knew then what I
know now hindsight I could have designed
the system better I understand the
system I understand the relationship of
parts better so that's another argument
for redesigning the system okay so these
are all reasons why we want we want to
redesign a system okay even Brooks who
had this wonderful idea of build one and
throw it out he rewrote things himself
it turns out he had second thoughts all
of the lessons that he learned
on that he wrote into the mythical
man-month were from his experience on a
project called os/360 well it turns out
that before elicit 360 there was a
project called stretch it's a really
interesting program that had memory
interleaving multi-programming it
literally bit off a lot tried to do a
lot of things really fascinating system
if you get a chance to read the book on
it and again you help stretch build
another one build os/360 build another
one so don't you don't get out of this
wanting to redesign things he even did
it to his own book the first time he
wrote the book he said build one and
throw it out then he said this is wrong
in the update to his edition that was
written 25 years later in 1995 he said
this is too radical and it's too
simplistic
um it's not just build a second one it's
constantly redesigning something he also
cautioned us against what is called the
second system effect so the first time
you build something you have very high
hopes very big aspirations you try to
put a lot of stuff in there but then you
actually build it and not everything
gets in but you make a list a list of
everything you wish you had done right
everything that you left out when you
build a second system you're a little
too eager it turns out to want to put
all that back in and so the second
system often ends up being worse than
the first and maybe the third is the one
that is the one that you're gonna like
it depends so this is the the thing to
consider about this idea of rebooting
and redesigning re-architected okay
here's some good examples if you're not
familiar with it the some reboots
besides the Internet itself which I'll
talk about at the end Green Day if
you've heard of that band had an album
that they recorded they spent a long
time in the studio and at home writing
this album recording the album they had
the tapes the Masters in 2005 masters
for that album which was called
cigarettes and Valentine's was stolen
rather than trying to remember those
songs and recover them they started from
scratch the album that they wrote from
scratch after that was called American
Idiot and it was a commercial success it
was a success in terms of awards
it was way way one of their biggest hits
in terms of an album and yet they found
the Masters - cigarettes and Valentines
and people listen to it and say no it
was not as good it was a good thing you
started over there's a example from
engineering there's this bridge called
the Tacoma Narrows Bridge which is the
picture in your screen and it was built
a little bit wrong and winds came
through the channel where it was built
and started to make it oscillate and
it's showing the mechanical engineering
classes as an example of this
uncontrolled oscillation that keeps
building up the entire bridge ends up
galloping like a horse it just buckles
back and forth and back and forth and
eventually breaks they had to build a
second one daven brought up in his talk
the Shinkansen when we wanted faster
trains
everybody wanted faster trains America
wonder faster trains Japan wonder faster
trains when America wanted a faster
train we built the Axela
and we put it on the old tracks it turns
out that was a bad idea
Excel it doesn't go very fast it is
limited by the rails that it's on when
Japan built the Shinkansen they put down
new rails that made all the difference
okay we've had many examples of
operating systems that were completely
redesigned not backward-compatible some
of the dos windows evolution Apple went
from using a 68k processor to using it
turns out in the middle there another
processor and then using the x86 and and
x87 processors the internet itself had a
couple of transitions to go from old
protocols to new which were disruptive
or to do these incremental changes which
were not disruptive or to do things that
I'll call partly
which is the transition ipv6 so let's
look at that the internet and the pros
and cons of it people all love the
Internet people all use the internet but
not everybody understands that the
Internet is really really really simple
at the end of the day it's these three
rules and that's it
it's packets with your variable length
messages that are self-addressed it's
addresses that are global not local with
a little bit of structure in them and
its local forward ending decisions so
you do not have to look at everything in
the world to figure out where a packet
goes all you have to do is look at your
input for your outputs look at the
packet income those three things make
the Internet what it is the good news is
it had some successes the first thing it
did was unifying that was one of the
things it was supposed to do was
supposed to take a bunch of different
networks and connect them together and
it succeeded largely succeeded at being
the unifying layer you don't have to
worry about what protocols somebody else
speaks if they speak to the Internet you
speak the internet everybody or
everything works you go home okay
another thing that the internet does
best efforts good enough we don't worry
about a drop packet we don't throw a
hissy fit when it happens we don't
scream it's okay and what that says is
that it is more important to connect
everybody a little than it is to connect
anybody really really really good that's
the Emiquon e over performance and then
that said before this local decisions
for global behavior turns out to be very
important and very powerful because what
it does is it means that I can add a
network to the internet without having
to coordinate with two billion other
users okay and that's what helps people
want to join and join easily there are
however opportunities to improve the
internet made a couple of mistakes
David pointed out in his presentation
that an email we have a front address
but we don't actually have an official
part of the email protocol that tells
you the origin so you
how to reach to return a message to who
you think sent the packet you don't have
information on where the packet actually
came from that's part of why we have the
problem with spam that we have today it
turns out that TCP has a particular
thing it doesn't handshake
and it keeps a certain amount of State
at the endpoints when the connection is
over it leaves state at one of the end
points to make sure that it won't reuse
packets inappropriately
it turns out that the party that ends up
holding that state is the party that
closes the connection not the party that
opens it what does that mean and why is
that important well I might run a web
server to a million people and a million
individuals each open one connection
then they close it now I am stuck
holding the bag on a million connections
if we had designed things the other way
around everybody would just hold one
which would be a lot easier and a lot
more scalable okay um there's this idea
of the fields in a packet are they fixed
length
are they extensible extensible fields
are something called PL these type of
blank value so it says I am source
directed message source directed message
as a length of 14 bytes and the value of
the 14 bytes is such as such as TLV they
have pros and cons fixed packets headers
are easier to parse much faster in
hardware PL these are less much more
extensible we also when we started the
Internet we gave out chunks of addresses
but we didn't worry about how many
addresses people were going to use and
all of a sudden we ended up giving out
16 million addresses or so to MIT now is
MIT have 16 million users or 16 million
computers no did they need that many
addresses
no but they dot that many and now that
we gave them that it's hard to get them
back that's part of how we ran out of
the dresses and finally the endian
choice there's this thing called ambien
little I'd be in big ambient when
have a four byte or an 8 byte structure
multibyte structure the Ascended low
byte 1st or high bite first the internet
says high bite first and almost all of
our hardware says low by you first
thanks so because two different groups
made two different decisions we end up
translating things all over the place
and it costs us about 20 or 30 percent
performance for the other one big things
we got wrong seven layer model the
internet is not made of seven layers
it's not made of Swiss cheese okay that
was a model that was proposed it was
used to explain things never really
mapped to reality very well and was
implemented only as a prototype that
never actually ran outside of test
environments the local subnetting issue
security boundaries versus the way
multics does things as they've mentioned
security is a thing that the internet
didn't get quite right and also in some
sense the Internet has been largely
influenced by people who think it
security is binary
you're either secure or you're insecure
and if I told you that you you know
let's say you ride your bicycle to
campus okay and I said you're you know
everything has to have a lock on it okay
and your car has a lock and the car lock
is a hundred pounds you can say what's
fine it's car no problem okay your bike
lock is a hundred pounds and you have to
use it if you want to be secure what
would you do you leave the lock at home
and a lot of internet security is like
that it is so expensive in terms of
power and CPU processing that people
don't turn it on and that's a problem
and the problem is that we gave them no
choices okay so what does a good
architecture look like if we're
designing thing from scratch we want and
have a good idea of what wanna do it
turns out that there are some principles
we can use here good architecture is
like a good list and to me a good list
is defined as something that is a list
of ideas or concepts or components where
you have nothing that you want to add
nothing to get rid of
all the pieces are about the same size
and scope and nothing overlaps if you do
that you've got a good handle on the
architecture but in architecture should
also map to things it provides an
analogy to what's going on we call that
a conceptual homomorphism it should
predict existing behavior it should
predict new behavior it should give you
insight to how the system works okay you
should say well based on this
architecture I would expect the
following then you can test it that
again is another property of a good
architecture another thing about good
design and Dave brought this up at his
previous talk extensively is it's about
balance um there were a number of
companies Intel and Microsoft together
in particular who were all at the table
trying to get hardware security to work
this led largely to things like the
trusted platform module but the problem
was everybody wanted security
everybody wanted Hardware protection and
nobody thought anybody would pay even
two or three dollars for and that was
back before we started having supply
chain risk problems we started having
these attacks on our systems the the
ransomware things like that now I think
if you ask somebody would you pay two
extra dollars for something that was in
danger and somewhere and they pay it but
at the time that was not true ok multics
hardware software designed together good
balance between the two
but again shows the challenge of doing
this integrated design it took a longer
time to build because it was integrated
and because it was late on its schedule
it was largely replaced by Unix
obviously gonna be careful the perfect
is the enemy of good enough here and
microcode is another example of this
another an example of that hardware
software trade it's programmable but
almost nobody can be bugging because
once it's in a system it's hard to
change usually burnt in people don't
understand it there's no uniform way of
debugging
or analyzing it or changing it I can
list on three fingers a number of
systems I have seen in my life that had
micro code that could change one of them
was I believe not Silicon Graphics
doesn't there's an AI computer that you
could reload and on a Tuesday it would
do one thing in our lives another thing
but that's just not very common okay so
what if now we're gonna now we're going
to throw some rocks and we're gonna see
what we can break cuz you know breaking
things is fun so we want to ask that
question what happens how can we break
things
the reason we're asking what if is
because we want to do three things we
want to challenge our assumptions we may
not even know what assumptions we have
made when we started designing the
system and now we live with an everyday
okay
those assumptions become constraints and
they limit how you design the system and
how you use the system we're going to
challenge that the context that they've
invention the assumptions about what
environment you're running in and what
resources you have you also want to
challenge the expectations about what
the system can do if we only ever give
somebody one thing they will be content
Steve Jobs once said that the customer
doesn't know what they want until I show
it to them and this is another example
of that to challenge expectations so
let's consider some assumptions in the
internet most stub networks that network
at the edge of a network our broadcast
most of them are actually Ethernet in
particular that influence is how our
protocols work almost all of our
protocols have built into them at some
level the notion of broadcast broadcast
is very very very expensive except in
Ethernet at the edge okay and we have it
because it was there when we started
designing networks we assumed it as we
went forward and we didn't even know we
made the assumption and now we're stuck
with it in some sense
okay another example when you connect to
somebody when you exchange package with
somebody even if you don't connect you
send large streams of packets many many
packets one after the other
many many round-trip times and so you
assume that maybe you don't think new
things right the first round trip but
you get it right after about ten or
twenty and that's okay I don't have to
be great the first time through the
system as long as I can correct ok we
also assume the packets are pretty small
and that allows us to share bandwidth on
low speed links in fact ATMs cell size
of 53 bytes is only 53 because of
wanting to share a voice link we don't
need to share voice links per se anymore
we don't do it on a 64 kilobit per
second channel I don't use those very
much at all anymore and so here we have
a network architecture ATM asynchronous
transfer mode by the way not the place
where you get money that is making an
assumption about packet size based on
channel speed that didn't exist
effectively at the time it was designed
in the late eighties how do you build a
network that's designed to handle 10
gigabit channels when you're really
thinking about 64 kilobit channels the
answer is you don't
so here's the first rock everybody step
back I'm gonna throw it okay the first
Rock is what happens if there's no
subnets currently the way we figure out
how to get across a network the way we
do art the way we do neighbor discovery
the way we do duplicate address
detection endpoint configuration
multicast
is all based on the ability to send one
packet
they haven't though many places at once
so what if all links were actually
unicast well we hit this problem a long
time ago there's an RFC on it called RFC
that introduces a concept called Lane
LAN emulation what it does is it says
instead of broadcasting I will always
send my request to one place in the
okay so now we have instead of broadcast
we have a famine problem that's not
scalable that's okay if you didn't
realize it
broadcast isn't scalable either so would
we want to keep that would we want to
change that this is the question that it
makes us ask now let's look at what
happened when we go faster turns out
everybody thinks when you get a faster
internet connection the packets go
faster it's actually not true at all the
packet head always takes the same amount
of time through the link depending upon
what link it is whether it's a wire or
whether it's a fiber or something else
but if it's a fiber that goes one
megabit per second or a fiber that goes
a pyramid that first bit is going
exactly the same speed okay what happens
to packets is they shrink they get
shorter in time and longer in bandwidth
so you see you in the diagram there how
a long packet that takes up a long piece
of time to send that or a long people
message it takes a lot of packets takes
a long piece of time when I send it over
faster link the head of the pack against
they're exactly the same time but the
tail gets there faster so we see that
the transfer happens quicker so if I
look at the bottom of the slide there
you'll see that I have a handshake then
I have this long transmission of data
and then another handshake that's what
happens that we're slowly the faster the
link is this the less time I spend
sending that data because it's my
bandwidth the more time those handshakes
matter over the fastest links that you
can get I still have to do that
handshake but I spent almost no time
setting the data okay so given that
let's look at things and ask a question
again
ready throw the rock what happens if my
flows instead of being hundreds
thousands millions of packets and tens
dozens hundreds of round-trip times I
only send one packet this will break
almost everything
the internet because that this deputy is
designed to deal with flow control or
congestion control plus all of it is
based on the idea that I mess up in the
short term but it all evens out over the
steady-state well if I only send one
packet there is no steady-state okay and
so if that's true and I send one packet
every single time and I do that only I
get in trouble really really fast all of
my congestion flow control the internet
will not work all of my queuing
mechanism isn't feedback mechanisms will
not work okay we would have to redesign
the Internet this is a good reason okay
now let's look at that packet the MTU
the larger packet that we can send in
the network has not changed since we
started designing networks it was 1500
bytes when we started or 500 bytes
already started it went up to 1500 bytes
pretty quick it's now about 1200 bytes
but it really hasn't gotten big it might
be appropriate instead of thinking how
big the packet is to ask how big it
should be if I said if everybody has a
hundred times the bandwidth they used to
have can't I just send a package that's
100 times bigger and wouldn't that be
more efficient maybe packets should be a
microsecond whatever that is on your
link it's what it is as the bandwidth
gets tighter maybe the packets get
bigger maybe they're just large maybe
the packet is larger than the entire
around for bandwidth delay product of
your system okay what if the packet was
so big you couldn't store-and-forward it
what would you have to do different okay
again we're throwing rocks here our
context here when we started off the
internet we had limited CPU that's why
the original processors the imps were
outboard they were separate devices
because you didn't want the CPU of your
system which was busy doing you know
text on a screen or vectors on a diagram
to be bombarded with the idea of
building packets so you had to push that
out to this outboard processor
we have limited memory and disk till
about 20 years ago and we had software
to deal with that compression on-demand
access things like that until about 10
years ago we had limited bandwidth okay
so we had compression and synchronous
exchanges to deal with that before ipv6
we had limited addresses so we had to
use Macs and we were error-prone
throughout so we had to do all this
error detection of collection so
consider that context and this is the
question and Dave will love this because
this goes way back this was the question
of my thesis
what if bandwidth instead of being a
constraint was a resource I asked that
question in 1992 and I got the looks you
can imagine at that time are you crazy
okay at the time 2400 bits per second
modems or 4840 K bits per second modems
were all the rage nobody had a mag
nobody had ten and when he had a hungry
nobody could spell the word gigabit much
less pronounce it we all know that there
with limits the usage and so we are
still in fact bandwidth limited my house
is not particularly bandwidth rich and I
have a hundred megabits per second but
what are you speed tests I usually don't
get close to that I want to try to
download something from a real site I
never get that okay
what happens if bandwidth were free and
that was my thesis question and the
answer is instead of prefetching you
push and so you touch Google and while
you're sitting there watching the TV or
looking at something else Google should
be sending everything it can every link
on every page every page that points to
every page that points to etc what would
that do for you well we looked at it and
in 1996 we asked the question how much
bandwidth could you actually use and at
the time we were happy with things like
ISDN 64 kilobits per second links or
maybe what was called it
one liner 1.5 Megadeth week and we have
a budget of a hundred milliseconds of
latency that human beings are
comfortable thinking about and
comfortable with that delay so in a
hundred milliseconds
what could you send you see the curves
here well it turns out that at the time
you could do web browser pretty
effectively not frustrating people but
if you started putting too many icons on
your page or using a high res screen
everything ground to a halt and people
were very unhappy they said hey a
network is slow I need a better network
and we said okay what network do you
need so here's the question you might
ask yourself how much bandwidth you
actually need at your house and I will
propose that the bandwidth that you need
is defined by the bits on your screen
okay
at the time in 1996 this is again 24
years ago I said that if you had 300
dots per inch
you probably want somewhere between 100
and 500 megabits per second to be happy
with the click speed in the response
time of your network well guess what
that's a Retina display 300 bits per
inch okay or 300 dots per inch and
that's the home bandwidth that we've
kind of topped out at right now and yes
Internet companies will try and tell you
you need a gigabit you should pay them
another $100 a month we're here to tell
you you don't we don't need that until
you start having higher resolution
screens 500 off 4-inch $1,000 vision
they're coming we haven't seen them yet
but they're gonna come from at max point
it's pretty random
okay but you can look at this and you
can look ahead 24 years ago you could
look ahead okay another question right
now most of our endpoints have one IP
address what if that wasn't true well if
the address to host ratio was greater
than 1 we have multihoming and os server
parallelism and that's the VMS and
things like that to do now when we start
having
addresses pearls it also had less the
idea of an app is not just because the
internet guys want to charge you more
money for our network connections so
that you can run servers
it actually has other reasons for
existing and maybe that's a good thing
so what if the address the host ratio is
less than one what if you didn't start
off assuming that all endpoints had IP
addresses what would change how would
you identify your endpoints right now we
do it with a bit of a hack frankly how
would we do this if we wanted to make it
broader names we have names on the
Internet we have DNS names we have IP
addresses if you look in the bottom
corner of your screen you'll see a email
address and a phone whether those names
have a property that I mentioned the
beginning of this talk they're ephemeral
they go poof they disappear they are the
email and phone equivalent of these of
snapchat okay so I'm sending these
messages and they're gonna disappear the
time the talk is over so we you know we
don't continually have questions every
time everybody looks at the talk because
I'm not gonna you know answer the
questions that are not online when you
are thinking about addresses you think
maybe that the addresses should have a
time time they're valid okay we have a
link that we used for this talk we
emailed that link around it would be
nice if encoded in the link was the
information that said when the link was
active hey what if they have other
properties what if they had a virtual ID
like a VPN ID or a security ID okay well
it turns out getting to security
security is very expensive it's very
high bandwidth costs slows things down
by a factor somewhere between two and
four it adds delays because you're
storing forward algorithms you block
things together in order to do
encryption it also has a very high
processing load which you know on your
cell phone means you burn your battery
down if your laptop you you need a
bigger processor or more cooling
or can't run those Bitcoin algorithms um
and it requires key infrastructure so
let's look at all those things so what
if security were cheaper instead of
all-or-nothing we could do something
that was faster quicker or lighter or in
fact anonymous turns out those are
useful we had looked into a variety of
these things and said what if you do
Jimmy Hellman but you don't worry about
having an x.509 key you get some
security
you just don't know who you're getting
security to it turns out that's still
useful in some cases and we created my
ETF working group called buttons to do
that better than nothing security you
can do layered checks on your packets
which gives you a weak check so that you
don't spend all your CPU time throwing
out something you're probably going to
throw out any ok uh you can do
parallelism and chaining that is again a
little bit weaker but higher performance
you can also do things over smaller
units than a packet and again drive that
store-and-forward latency down there's a
lot of opportunities here now want to be
careful there are a lot of toys that
people have built if you will or ideas
that people have explored in the
internet the clean slate architecture
program active net Software Defined
Networking Information Center in that
Green Valley tolerant networking those
are examples they could be good in their
environment for a particular thing but
let me caution you and not necessarily
to point those out as being examples of
this but here's the thing
just because you say take something and
change it to the opposite being a
contrarian doesn't mean you have an
answer
it may mean you have a direction a new
idea of something to do but Maslow is a
philosopher who said if the only tool
you have is a hammer everything starts
to look like a nail and it's very true
and let's so if you switch something up
before you figure out what you're gonna
do with it say I found the answer if
only I turned my car upside down I won't
wear out the tires great ok
you're gonna wear out the roof okay it's
not gonna roll very well and so you have
to be careful of just saying I'm gonna
flip things upside down and change the
script and come up with an answer okay
other benefits of asking what if for
those of you in the audience buried in
this talk and these questions and other
questions are very interesting projects
very interesting papers a ton of PhD
theses or sabbatical if you've already
got a PhD so feel free dig in there's a
lot of ideas here but the point here is
to get you to ask your own questions to
get your own rocks and throw them at
things and see what you can break okay I
did this and I looked at networking and
asked the question of what if okay so
here's an example I looked at the
network and said the internet
architecture that we haven't said well
we have a problem we have this seven
layer architecture that everybody seems
to know and love but it breaks all over
the place
what is IPSec oh that's layer three
point two or three point five what's I
piece it or what's MPLS that's layer two
point five if you have to put a decimal
you don't have layers anymore
where do these protocols fit in where
does art nobody can tell you where art
is it's not part of the model we have
layers on top of layers if IP is layer
three because Ethernet is layer two and
TCP is layer four then what is IP over
IP are they both layer three that breaks
that model again what is IP over UDP
I've got three over four over three okay
and I've got these things that we call
the control plane and the management
plane in the naming plane and everybody
says oh we have this beautiful seven
layer stack and when we had this thing
on the side that doesn't fit in and I
looked at that and said okay that's
busted what can we do that's different
than that so I looked about again back
to the architecture and said that seven
layer model never was
okay that a lot of what the way we were
doing protocols is very ad hoc and a lot
of what we built as internet
architecture was very arch or collage it
was oh we do want here
oh we need this let's do that we need
this let's do that but nobody was
stepping back and saying what does the
whole landscape look like do these
pieces make sense where's the science
we're computer scientists right where's
the science where's the foundation if
you took a science class let's say you
took physics you would start off with
Newton's three laws of motion you took a
biology class you'd start off with
taxonomy of the biological systems okay
if you take chemistry you start off with
a bunch of principles there are our
fundamental principles we don't have
them we tend to think of networking and
internet architecture as oh well let me
tell you how people built it if we think
that we need a reboot maybe part of the
reason we need to reboot is we didn't
have that grand vision of the foundation
so here's a good example of what I think
is that foundation I started an idea
called the first principles approach to
computer networking economy developed
the class 1800 slides taught at USC for
a couple of years gave it to a bunch of
other professors at USC UCLA in a couple
of the places who are also teaching it
and I'm currently working on this as a
textbook the idea is that you start with
something that can't be arguing
information theory two-party shared
state then you extend it to multi party
multicom multiple scales and you
leverage the only tools that I think we
haven't CS and when I look at CS I think
of all the tools we have that are unique
just yes we have math they have group
theory but that's math right you have
language theory but that's that's also
kind of math the things that we have
that nobody else has our abstraction and
recursion okay and so if you build a
model out of this you can get an
integrated system that actually explains
layering forwarding and name resolution
and
everything at once so our three laws of
motion are my view shanon's
communication theory
it says shared state between excels you
have the shared state between two given
parties that are directly connected by a
perfect channel that's your starting
point start with that and then relax all
of the phrases that are underlined see
what you can get how do you figure out
which party they're talking to how do
you do in direct connections and how do
you deal with errors and by dealing with
those two or three things you build an
architecture you have a logical
progression from communication theory
multi-party layering to naming to
recursion and you build everything
here's the example you start with a
perfect Channel you add errors then you
show how you make a channel real like
you a channel is this philosophical
mathematical concept and it turns out
that if you build it you have to throw
things at people in physics there are
only two things you can throw at
somebody turns out fermions and bosons
and they have properties and
interestingly enough if you think of the
properties of fermions and bosons from
physics it tells you a lot about how we
design link protocols so again this all
comes from first principles and then we
build finite state machines to be able
to influence okay multi-party to relay
how do we do the transition from
assuming that everybody is directly
connected to they're not how do we do
shared channels which is back to that
Fermi on a boson example how do we do
implicit shared channels with token
passing a token ring then how do we do
relay to emulate that layering turns out
to be not a seven answer problem but
this recursive concept of abstraction we
abstract a layer so that we can deal
with both heterogeneity and scale there
are two ways we can layer by translation
converting between things and by
encapsulation which is sort of stacking
things as we do now and it turns out
that you want to combine the two you
encapsulate the data and translate the
headers okay naming is not this separate
thing
outside of a network it's an integral
part to what happens of enough in a
network and so it has to be built into
that layering mechanism that translation
mechanism as though the ways that we do
it
the resolution mechanisms the idea of
the operating systems names versus the
names inside the network and how we set
names up automatically okay and finally
recursion now on the screen is what
looks like a very complicated diagram of
different protocols with different name
translation cables between them and you
know many of these cables there's like
an art cable in there there's your
socket table there's your DNS table
that's where those tables are okay the
tables are in blue the orange part are
the things we call protocols we don't
have a protocol stack we have a directed
acyclic graph it turns out that starts
at the application at the top and ends
up at the interfaces at the bottom which
are perfect now if you look at this
algorithm in this data structure and you
traverse it using a recursive piece of
software you get everything that we do
in networking it turns out the path that
you take through the Hat is pushed on to
the front of your packets it turns out
that we do have a stack it's not the
stack of protocols
it's the stack of headers we push and
pop off of the date off of the packet to
keep track of where we are in that state
machine okay but the state machines more
complicated this state machine can shift
from TCP to a wired socket without
affecting the application okay this
machine could translate between TCP and
UDP without affecting the application in
ways that the existing stacks can't and
it turns out when we back up a second
there that going down that path and also
going between nodes in a network is the
same mechanism okay one is recursion and
the other if you know recursion is tail
recursion is how you can walk across so
it turns out that with one neck
and we can integrate naming which is the
blue boxes with the protocols the orange
boxes with the way we Traverse them with
the way we encode them into the headers
with the way we build the endpoint up
and down with the way we go across the
network all one thing okay and it turns
out that a lot of the stuff that we
study otherwise in networking is
optimization dealing with errors of
deficiencies like corruption and loss
and tampering and authentication of
privacy the red part up there is what we
call security but they're just
deficiencies dealing with performance
and dealing with emulation okay it turns
out that if you do things this way again
if you're a rock and broke the internet
now I'm saying how to fix it I come up
with an architecture that actually the
Internet and the OSI models are
degenerate cases of that's what a model
should do it should give you the
existing stuff fresh explain existing
stuff but it extends to explain places
where the existing stuff doesn't work I
no longer have a problem understanding
what IP over IP is or IP over UDP over
IP is okay there just passed through
that back okay I don't have a problem
thinking about those control plate
management plain naming plain they're
all part of the same thing okay but and
again I predict something the Internet
can't do and I would have not have
thought of this until I look back at my
model and said what could my model do
that the Internet can and it changed the
transport protocol on the fly to the
application without any effect
that's that late binding okay and the
key to this is that I'm just trying to
figure out why does the internet do what
it does not what does it do now I think
if you want to understand something you
need to ask why okay
so I've given you some reasons to reboot
I've given you some examples of the
Internet's pros and cons and reasons
that you want to reboot it I'll give you
an example of how I thought of rebooting
the internet or at least for teaching
purposes as an architecture that may not
be the
be part of the internet water reboot but
that's why okay now you want to reboot
how do you reboot you've got this big
chasm that you have to get across this
big gap how do you get from the old to
the new well you can evolve things
incrementally you can go like HTTP 1.1
to 2 point 1 point 2 to 2.0 multipath
tcp is built on TCP quic is built on UDP
we have emulation libraries when Apple
shifted to the x86 architecture they
didn't stop the presses they made things
run with emulation or libraries okay
that's one way to do is to evolve a
completely different way of doing things
is to replace the NCP to tcp/ip
transition in January of 1983 is a good
example but the important example I want
to point out here is we talked about
multics and it's not its multix not you
read Alex ok we have a phrase in
networking or in many things of
something called a Flag Day which is the
day web before the Flag Day you have the
old one and after the flag then you have
the new one and the reason we have the
phrase Flag Day is because multix
changed versions of the way of
representing text ASCII text on June
14th 1966 which is the day in the United
States we celebrate the flag called Flag
Day in the United States
so a Flag Day happened on Flag Day in
the United States first ok um you can
also combine the two approaches of
evolving and replacing as we've done as
well there are competing interests here
vendors want their stuff to work with
everybody else's but they want you to
buy their stuff so my car is just like
everybody else's car when you want to
drive it but my car has special things
other cars don't have so you either want
to break into a market a corner it and
by doing that you often end up pushing
things in different directions do you
design for today or tomorrow right are
you trying to sell something cheap or
build something that somebody can use it
for years okay are you trying to absorb
everything that everybody does around
you that's born from from Star Trek or
are you trying to say no no no you
didn't follow the rules that I set down
it turns out that comes from the concept
called the Hammurabi code which a couple
of slides back I had that that stone
tablet up
that's the Hammurabi code that's the
difference between Linux and BSD both of
them were successors to Unix both of
them were free both of the mortgage in
Jamin to be relatively open but in both
cases somebody having controlled a curl
- Torvalds controlled the Linux can turn
kernel and the BSD consortium controlled
the BSD current when new software came
out new drivers new operating system
features etc Linus said I'll take it
and he took everything he had that board
mentality take one of everything
BSD said if we don't know where I came
from and we don't think we can trust it
no it doesn't go in which is exactly why
everything works on Linux or mostly
everything will work at least once on
Linux but BSD is more stable the reason
everything runs on Linux is because they
never saw a driver they didn't like
whether they trusted it or not whereas
BSD will only take trusted stuff are you
designing for correctness or speed
coding speed running speed whatever you
got to make that decision the innovators
dilemma there's a book on this as well
if you haven't read it's a good one
large companies do not innovate well
because they don't want to abandon their
big markets you do not look to Ford to
build something that puts cars out of a
job they sell cars they don't want to
stop selling cars so they're not going
to come up with scooters okay um so it's
got to be the little companies you take
that risk
then there's the funders dilemma and
I'll say this with all due respect the
National Science Foundation and DARPA in
the u.s. fund a lot of the research that
they have some peculiarities the NSF
often gives money out only one student
and they're trying
now limits the size and scope of what
you can do okay
Dartmouth focuses on results doesn't
really do a lot of research they want to
see it work they want to see results
they want they don't want to say maybe
it's gonna work even though they say
that and their brochures they're really
focused on results who wants to see
products they don't want to pay for
something that you can use in 20 years
used to be they did invest in that you
can blame Michael Milken for the reason
we don't do that anymore
companies can't afford to invest in
long-term research anymore because the
companies that don't can outsell the
companies that do because they can sell
their stuff cheaper because they're not
subsidizing research but then we don't
end up with those pearls that we invent
because we didn't know we were looking
for them and we didn't know what we were
going to do with them when they diverted
them AT&T came up with the transistor
AT&T came up with Unix neither one of
those was designed for an immediate
product he was designed to use money
that was set aside for long-term
research we don't have that anymore
we're not gonna get the next big idea
from these companies because they're not
pretty moving in there and then the
United States in particular has this
problem with alternative facts they
don't like that phrase back to the fact
fictions fiction this idea that that
everything has two sides or everything
has three sides is not always true if it
is it's gonna limit how you look at
things so you got to be careful and
finally we look at some of these other
things where does their cycles in the
way we do things there are times when
everybody said do all your processing in
bored there's times when they said move
it out it's a pendulum every time you
look at the clock you're gonna see a
different answer okay some systems have
support for some systems have support
for none there's also ambiguous answers
there's no good answer to extensible
versus fixed fields they both have their
place you can't say oh I'm only going to
do one thing and that's it okay the same
with complex systems versus reduced
instruction systems you have to you have
to accept that you're just going to go
back and forth however sometimes we
have to break the cycle okay I hear a
lot of people talking about worrying
about changing certain things and
putting whole industries out of a job
okay if you have too many uber drivers
you put taxis out of the job if you have
too many streaming services you're gonna
put the radio companies that the record
companies out of a job well guess what
when my grandmother came to the United
States she had a refrigerator and she
didn't call her refrigerator she called
it an icebox because that's what it was
it was a box in which you put ice they
kept your food cold and the ice man
would come around every so often and
sell you a block of ice to put in your
fridge and then somebody came up with
this brilliant idea that we could
refrigerate using electricity okay
that meant the Iceman was out of a job
did we worry about that no we moved on
if you think about how Pistons work and
there's a limit to how fast a piston can
move a propeller but not a jet you
cannot break the speed of sound with a
piston you can't break the speed of
sound with a propeller because the
propeller has to break the speed of
Scone way before the jet has to break
the speeds down or the aircraft okay so
some of these times there's changes that
just leave you behind in the dust and
you have to adapt to and sometimes
there's changes that get forced on you
either way you've got to deal with it
these are how you break that cycle
so finally Sisyphus was right
you're always rolling the rock back up
the hill and it's always coming down on
you and crushing you no matter when you
design a system you're always going to
have to be redesigning it so plan to
redesign your system plan to throw rocks
at it plan to reboot plan to think of
this don't assume everything that is is
the way it is and will always be start
asking those hard questions start
breaking windows and
you know anything about design we know
that disorder rules you don't have to do
anything to a system to have it end up
just accreting bad things mistakes bugs
additions to many viewpoints all sorts
of things in it and you're gonna have to
clean it up no matter what you do okay
when we're done and we say we want to
rebuild the Internet we're gonna have 2x
ask somebody to help again who's gonna
help us we're gonna have to do this
ourselves there was no organization we
went to that magically said we will
stand behind this and it'll work
DARPA and the NSF did fund the internet
evolution for the 2025 years they didn't
say that when they started we didn't
know they were going to do that okay all
we knew was they were going to start the
first project so have some hope for that
the Internet Society is not going to be
the place that this happens the IE
tensions to patch things and the IAB is
called the internet architecture board
but architecture isn't anything that we
do anymore as I said the NSF only funds
one student at a time and DARPA they say
they want a revolution but not evolution
but they spend in my opinion a lot more
time celebrating anniversaries than they
do celebrating inauguration and if you
want somebody to listen right now I say
advisor
find someplace to send a paper or just
put the paper out on arxiv and see what
you can get people to respond to but
start thinking about it and do it this
doesn't happen because somebody says you
can do it this doesn't happen because
somebody lets you do it it happens
because you do it this talk wasn't
prepared in a vacuum it's based largely
on a couple of talks that David given at
Keio University they're cited up top
here and a large body of work that I had
accumulated over many years at the
bottom in the PDF of this file there are
links if you have problems finding
anything going to the stray alpha comm
website and also go to the KO website to
find Dave stuff and thank you very much
for listening if anybody have any
questions I didn't see any cop in yeah
and the interesting thing about cable
that I heard at least was that one of
the problems with the way in which cable
internet was deployed in the US was
there's sort of a hierarchy of
distributors that went from the head end
down to the the last box in your
neighborhood and the Assumption at one
point was that a single box could handle
a hundred homes but they didn't the
original installers didn't measure
traffic which is closer to twenty to one
and so that's why there's this whole
issue on people saying that if the cable
works great when it comes to your
neighborhood until all your neighbors
get on cable because they didn't put
enough of these boxes in at a low enough
level of the hierarchy because they
hadn't measured the upload versus
downloads alone OSCON the world changed
well they but the switches do the
switches generally have multicast or
broadcast built into them they either do
igmp snooping or the broadcasts ends one
to every port and so you get broadcast
for free it has to the ethernet
protocols depend upon right and that's
one of the one of the lectures that I
had for this this first principles and
networking class explains that at least
in my view switches are really just ways
to emulate show me to get well the other
problem practically was that Ethernet
when you look at signal annoys problems
that you get in the ethernet protocols
it doesn't work very well right if you
have a real Ethernet so in fact it was a
instant migration to switches you know
Metcalfe and I use dog-doo because if
you looked at a ring which I was
building the natural way to make a ring
was to build it into a switch and the
ephah never went into a switch and you
couldn't no difference that's right yeah
just ways of sharing the media right
right you know I add one one thing to
the to the talk if I can this there's
some fundamental problems Joe has been
talking about essentially software and
there are big big problems with our
hardware which are not easy to come get
around and we have processors which
cannot be secured we just found out from
Intel
well an AMD has the same problem yeah we
yeah we've been hearing about them
almost weekly of different there's been
a different problem almost weekly goes
back to the problem that in fact
processors now have a huge amount of
micro code and use complexity but there
are there are other issues nobody ever
built
I take that back they have been
computers built to be trusted or
insecure
both text one of them realize bolt X was
it was running up and sort of mid-90s at
NSA doing his job so it wasn't a failure
just two too long to build right the but
I think when you look at where we go
next
especially since we're at some point in
the future we're going to get the type
of hybrid computing that that a
conventional computing and quantum
computing you're going to get together
probably not as replacements but as as
service the way we do it now with many
things that's going to require and
quanta and quantum networks beginning to
show fairly soon at some levels and
that's going to force us to rethink
everything and at all levels and it's
going to be very difficult to patch yeah
it's really spectacular opportunities to
really sort of throw anything away that
doesn't mean that you're going to throw
away the hundreds of millions of people
who use the Internet you know we still
use telephones we still use a lot of
stuff that that's quote obsolete but it
will mean to enforce many applications
with even security or performance are
required we're gonna have to rethink
things and of calm oh thank real briefly
wanted to thank you Andy and and Dennis
Ellison for inviting us to present